Republican Senator Rand Paul is backing
president Trump's decision to withdraw
US troops from northern Syria the
Kentucky lawmaker who ran against
President Trump in the 2016 election has
become a supporter of his foreign policy
Senator Paul's new book is called the
case against socialism he writes about
US politics including 2020 presidential
contender senator Bernie Sanders
Senator Paul joins us now for his first
television interview about the book
senator good morning let me start with
Syria if I can because in a report from
Syria earlier in this broadcast our
Charlie d'Agata said Kurdish fighters
feel abandoned and betrayed have we
turned our backs on our allies and put
us and it's kind of left ourselves in a
vulnerable position with Isis you know I
think initially when President Trump
decided to go in he said that our goal
was to defeat Isis I think we've
achieved that goal many people keep
shifting the goalposts many of the
neoconservatives like Lindsey Graham say
oh well now we're gonna stay til Iran
goes our until Syria's a country well
good luck I mean that could be a long
time it's a very complicated war really
think about what we're talking about
we're talking about 50 soldiers what
what kind of war do you go to with 50
soldiers I mean we're moving 50 soldiers
out of the onslaught of tens of
thousands of Turkish troops so really I
think it's a smart thing to do and it
reminds me of Beirut do you remember
putting three hundred people when Reagan
had 300 people in a barracks unprotected
and then there was a suicide bombing so
what I don't want to have happen I've
got three nephews who serve in the
military I don't want them to be sitting
ducks with 50 or 100 of them being
killed by a suicide bomber and then all
said we're drugged into a crate of war
who we're gonna fight we're gonna fight
Turkey our NATO ally we're gonna fight
the Kurds we're gonna fight Assad the
Russians the Iranians Iraqis I mean the
whole place is a mess if the Kurds have
been very loyal LSO what we what we need
is not 50 soldiers fighting a war what
we need is a multilateral group to sit
down and try to hammer out a peace I
actually think the Kurds are more likely
to try to find peace now that they know
that they're either gonna have to fight
or find peace so I think really maybe we
have been impeding Peace Talks maybe
this can encourage peace talks senator
could you clarify your position on
impeachment before we get to the book
here do you think it was appropriate for
president Trump to solicit foreign help
in the 2020 campaign or do you think it
was
but just not impeachable I think that
the American people want everybody to be
treated equally and so I think when they
see Joe Biden doing similar with similar
accusations that Joe Biden threatened
their aid if they didn't fire a
prosecutor that was looking into a
company where hunter Biden was making
$50,000 a month so I would say if that's
going on and then Democrat senators are
also threatened the aide and now
President Trump is saying they're saying
president Trump threatened the aide
sounds like everybody's threatening
Ukraine's aid over Ukraine doing what
they want them to do so if you want to
be equal people if you want to impeach
President Trump they should have
impeached you a Biden as well for
similar type of activities well no I
think it's not incorrect or wrong - it's
okay for the president to be you know
let me finish what I would say is that
aid that we give to other countries
should be contingent upon behavior and
whether or not we should have Ukraine
trying to eradicate corruption yes so
this was specifically about well I don't
ask the American people if they think 50
oh you're a senator why no but ask the
American people do you think fifty
thousand dollars a month that hundred
Biden was getting might be corrupt you
were running for president I think 16
would you have done this if you were
elected I think everybody has different
ways that they would approach things but
are you well the thing is is now we're
getting down to whether or not it's
personality and how he reacted in a
phone call do you impeach people because
he has a more direct way of approaching
that's not a question my question is is
writing about is it right or wrong
I think ask a foreign leader to help in
an election with by the way nearly 400
million dollars in aid hanging over his
eye I guess the thing is would you say
we can't invest corruption if they
happen to be political figures it's not
it's because we're talking he wasn't
speaking to broader corruption he was
speaking he used that word but he spoke
specifically about masu if hunter
Biden's father was an industrial magnate
in the United States you'd say it's okay
that he asked to investigate hundred
Biden just because he was a politician
you say he's somehow involved in
politics more than a politician is that
he's the Democratic frontrunner well I
think I think the chances of Joe Biden
actually being the nominee or almost
that's a that's a death or whatever I
would say is that the American people
want
corruption to be looked at equally they
want equal
protection under the law so if we're
gonna say what President Trump did was
wrong we're gonna have to say with Joe
Biden did was wrong
we have four we're not answering my
question why is it wrong I'm trying was
it wrong for Democratic senators came
forward and said hey if you don't keep
investigating from we're gonna get you
no vote against your aide
everybody Republican or Democrat are
doing the exact same thing so how can we
say it's impeachable on one side and
we're gonna excuse Joe Biden on the
other side notably absent as an answer
to the question of whether you Rand Paul
think it's an appropriate however I do
want to get to the book because
socialism is also in the news these days
you you write that people misunderstand
it they throw the term out there but
when you ask them to actually define it
it's a much more problematic thing so
these polls would show support kind of
misleading I think a lot of this next
generation the young people in our
country now that may be infatuated with
socialism may have forgotten that the
socialism of the last century has been
almost invariably associated with
genocide and famine people need to be
reminded of that
it hasn't been an accident it's been one
after another socialism has devolved
into authoritarianism nowadays the big
thing is oh well we want this kinder
gentler socials and we want Scandinavian
socialism well we make the point I think
very clearly and supported by facts that
one Scandinavia is not socialist it is a
big welfare state but the big lie you're
getting from the left in our country the
big lie that Bernie Sanders perpetuates
is oh but the rich people will pay for
it the top one percent will pay for it
that's not the way they do it in
Scandinavia the working class in the
middle class bear a huge burden of their
25% sales tax for everybody you have an
income tax of 60 percent that starts at
sixty thousand so they do have a lot of
so-called free stuff socialist kind of
stuff welfare stuff in Scandinavia but
the middle class pay for it nothing's
really for free they have enormous taxes
so it's a false allure in our country
when they say oh the top 1% is gonna pay
for this
it won't work there's not enough money
the middle class ultimately has to be
taxed Senator Paul you also talked a lot
in your book about finding common ground
how do you do that yeah how do you do
that when you look at the rhetoric
that's happening right that you've taken
able to answer a question here's the
thing I was at Columbia last night and
they asked me what are the things you'd
like about Bernie Sanders and the
interesting thing is he and I work
together on
of things for example on war whether or
not the president should be allowed to
go to war in Iran without Congress
voting on it and while you umbrella
might be able to do that how do you make
sure that the the president of the
United States and others who are even
more powerful positions or find that
common ground and have you actually
spoken to the president in reference to
Syria I have not
since the Syria since a decision to move
50 troops around I have not talked to
the president about our president bout
two weeks ago and every couple weeks I
do talk to the president what I would
say is that I think there's a miss
reporting of acrimony in our country
there's a lot of acrimony on the
internet there's a lot of acrimony
actually on television but when you go
to Washington you'll be surprised to
find that Bernie and I get along I mean
I've been to his office he's been to my
office we talk about things like
criminal justice reform we talk about
trying not to go to war without a
declaration we are we've we've worked
together on trying to end the war in
Yemen I don't like socialism I think
socialism disaster he's absolutely wrong
well guess what when we talk we don't
actually bring up socialism so I
disagree on that but we bring out
foreign policy and we get on just fine
all right well there are a lot of things
that social apparently may be able to
help with like paid for an Aleve and
healthcare and all the rest but maybe
there are other ways other than
socialism to get to those ends
I just where's the money find and find
them $1.00 short right now trying to do
the stuff you want from government if
you want more from government I say tell
me where to find the money
it is all about choices Senator Rand
Paul thank you very much we appreciate
you being here the case against
socialism goes on sale October 15th